afro was originally a manga created by a
guy named Takashi Okazaki it was turned
into a TV show by Spike TV and then we
actually got the game rights at the same
time that they got greenlit so both the
TV show and the game will be made
simultaneously so we've been a part of
that family for six seven years now the
story of Afro is basically about a young
kid whose father was killed in front of
him and his sort of journey to revenge
his father's death but an afro to I mean
we're making afro was actually adopted
you know by a group of people who loved
him and he turned on that family and so
this is a story of how his older
brother's going to find him to get him
really to repent for his sins it's a
story of as much of revenge and
responsibility to your family and weird
is that where do you draw that line as
the story goes on it actually deepen so
thoughts in the in the beginning it's
revenge it's retribution where kuma
wants to avenge the death of among
others whose younger sister but then as
you play the game as the story kind of
broadens and deepens you as a player
come to understand that revenge is not
necessarily the be-all and end-all of
existence
Afro Samurai 2 is an episodic game the
gameplay is structured around a
storyteller because we want the gameplay
to be fresh you're a partner in this
journey you could actually participate
in it be a fan in the way you couldn't
be when it came to the TV show the
episodes you know all linked together
automatically also your story wise one
of the things that we're hoping to do
with the way that the game is
constructed is incorporate feedback from
the players in each volume the player is
actually gaining combat styles through
all the new characters and storylines
they follow but also gameplay we want
do is half cool man an action-adventure
setting learning and doing new things
changing your character and molding it
to the gameplay that you see in this new
chapter actor was a very hardcore game
in the past we've shrunk to that down to
a very tactical situation where you're
hitting one button there's modifiers
you're updating your character and and
investing in that character styles the
music is the blue one it's a rock opera
right but in hip-hop every new volume
will have a completely new soundtrack
from a completely new contributor the
RZA has actually been the musical
director across the entire franchise I
need to get his soul into this franchise
and the easiest way to do that is to
give him a character that could go on
this journey with cool so he has this
whole story that fits into the Afro
universe and you actually it's an
ongoing story less he's not just some
person who's gonna be around though it's
not a cameo he is now a part of the
franchise which is hot sauce that's pot
Szigeti sauce that's like a gallon